usualmente un destino idílico for Myers
en la costa suroeste de Florida sufrió
graves inundaciones y es una de las
zonas del estado más golpeadas por el
huracán Ian que tocó tierra Con vientos
de 240 kilómetros por hora un poderoso
huracán que causó inundaciones de más de
un metro dejando algunos residentes
varados las autoridades estatales
informaron que la población se vio
diesmada sin embargo el gobernador de
Florida Run de santys dijo que lo peor
ya fue superado
la opinión de nuestro meteorólogos es
que probablemente ya ha alcanzado su
punto máximo y según los pronósticos
será menor de lo que ha sido hasta este
momento en las próximas horas Pero
sabemos que ha sido una gran tormenta y
ha hecho mucho daño tal como están
a medida que avanzaba tierra adentro el
huracán se degradó a categoría 1 pero
las intensas lluvias continuaron
azotando el estado de santis dijo que
varias personas que no evacua en las
zonas de alto riesgo pidieron ayuda pero
los equipos de rescate no pudieron
actuar de inmediato las autoridades
locales aún deben evaluar el alcance de
los daños por su parte el Gobierno
Federal prometió recursos para los
esfuerzos de recuperación estaremos allí
para ayudarlos a limpiar y reconstruir
para ayudar a que Florida vuelva a la
normalidad estaremos allí en cada paso
del camino después de cruzar el centro
de Florida se espera que Ian llegue al
Océano Atlántico al terminar el jueves